Okay, I think we're good. If I may have the first slide.
My name is
Michel Sadelain. I'm a professor of medicine at Columbia
University, where I direct the newly established
Institute for Cell Engineering and Therapy.
I'm thrilled to share the podium here today with
two luminaries of the field
who will be speaking soon after me.
I see they're busy talking right now.
But before we start and get into this discussion
of barriers to current cell
therapies, and in particular, engineered cell therapies, I'm just going to
provide a little background,
as I don't know if everyone here is familiar with immunology.
And there are three questions that I would like to quickly address.
What distinguishes a CAR T cell from a natural T cell?
At least for the beginners. What makes CAR T
cells so attractive for cancer immunotherapy?
And then why have CAR T cells not yet delivered
for solid tumors what C19 CAR T cells already
did for B cell malignancies?
So here are two CAR molecules, the first two to have been approved by the US
FDA back in 2017. I am going to assume that most
people in the audience are now familiar with at least the
basics of these synthetic receptors for antigen.
Both of these are specific for CD19, a
molecule I'll discuss in a minute,
and both of them
comprise this composite dual signaling module that you see there,
comprising the green chain, which typically is borrowed from the
CD3 zeta chain, which initiates the T cell activation,
which is complemented
by additional signaling modules.
The first one ever being that derived from CD28,
and the other one from 4-1BB. But I just want to, again,
address what's different about a CAR T cell compared to a natural T
cell. Well, natural T cells use the
physiological clonotypic T cell receptor, which is
embedded in the CD3 complex and can see inside
cells. The inside of cells is brought to the surface, laden
onto HLA molecules.
And their signaling
is tempered by a number of costimulatory molecules,
either inhibitory or activating, expressed into T cells.
B cells, on the other hand, also express a B cell receptor which
they can secrete in the form of an immunoglobulin.
And in doing so, they provide surveillance to the extracellular milieu
and cell surfaces. Note that immunoglobulins don't work
on their own. They need to recruit either proteins such
as complement or other cells such as macrophage or
NK cells to exert their action.
So what's different about a CAR T cell?
Well, CARs
function independently of CD3.
They're independent of HLA because they recognize
cell surface molecules.
And they harbor, as I just showed you, intrinsic
costimulation.
Unlike an antibody or a B cell receptor, they are not secreted.
They may engage any cell surface entity, and by any, I
mean a protein, a carbohydrate moiety, a
glycoprotein, a glycolipid, and also,
if necessary, an HLA peptide complex.
So if you ever hear that
CARs can't see what TCRs can see, that's not true.
CARs can be designed to see the exact same thing.
And then once they engage their target, they don't need to recruit an
auxiliary effector. The T cell is hooked up to the CAR and
ready to fire.
So what makes these cells so attractive for cancer immunotherapy?
Well, the first here is, like any engineered immune cells,
they bypass immune tolerance.
If someone's repertoire doesn't have the ability to
engage a particular antigen, well, when it's engineered, you've just bypassed
immune tolerance. That is true for all engineered receptors, not just
for CARs. But then they are not HLA restricted,
which means that they can see the
same antigen irrespective of the
restricting HLA.
And that means that they can be used in any patient without
having to pay attention to their
HLA haplotypes.
CARs allow for multi-targeted T cells.
Again, the clonotypic physiological receptor is one TCR per
cell.
But in the world of synthetic biology,
researchers are now designing multi-targeted T cells.
Importantly, the CAR, in contrast to the T cell receptor, is not just a targeting
device. It really reprograms functions and metabolism, and that's
through its costimulatory component.
And lastly, they're not limited to recognizing neoantigens, as I already said,
but I bring this up
to make the point made here, which is that
if you look at checkpoint blockade, which is circled in gray here, it is
most effective in cancers with a high mutational burden,
presumably because there's a higher probability that in the face of
many exonic mutations, there will be TCRs that can
recognize them.
But a lot of cancers harbor
lower mutational burdens, and that's where checkpoint blockade
typically does not work so well. And that is the area where,
in particular, we think that CAR T cells
will be the most useful. So why have they not yet delivered for solid
tumors what C19 CARs
delivered for hematological malignancies?
So just a few wordsTo start from CD19
because it is sort of the
foundation, if you like, for this field at this time.
Why was it chosen? Well, it was chosen because,
for many reasons, I'll just highlight a few.
In particular, we knew from bone marrow transplant in particular, that T cells
traffic very nicely in leukemias and lymphomas.
And these cancers, of course,
frequently are CD19 positive.
CD19 is highly restricted to the B-cell lineage.
And a B-cell aplasia induced by a CAR T cell would be not
ideal, but manageable.
Importantly, it was also chosen because we thought that it
might circumvent any immune response against the CAR,
which is a composite molecule and
is likely to be immunogenic in patients.
And why not CD20? I'm going back to the mid-'90s here when we chose to
work on CD19. CD20 was already famous, the
target of rituximab, but we chose CD19 because it's more
abundant at the cell surface. It's more broadly expressed earlier and a bit later
along the B-cell lineages and appeared to be
pan-tumor expressed across all tumors in most
patients.
So finally,
what's the difference between targeting solid tumors and this
paradigmatic CD19? Well, entry into tumors with CD19, as I just
said,
it seemed to be a favorable situation. That's not the case in solid tumors.
T cells don't get into every solid tumor.
Solid tumors have stronger immune suppression mechanisms
in their microenvironment, and again, that's tougher than the scenario
for CD19.
How long do these cells need to persist?
Well, it may be that they don't need to persist that long for leukemia or
lymphoma or multiple myeloma, but they probably need to persist
longer in solid tumors.
CARs can be immunologically rejected.
Well, as I said, targeting CD19 could circumvent
at least an antibody response, but then that's not the case for
CARs targeting solid tumors. And finally, identifying
suitable molecular targets. Well, CD19
has worked very well, but that's not so obvious in solid tumors.
So this have said, I'd like to now open the session, and
our first
speaker is
Steve Forman,
who is a professor of hematology and oncology at the City of Hope in Duarte,
California, and he will be discussing his recent
findings
on CAR T-cell therapies. Steve.
Thank you.
Thank you, Michel. Nice to be here with you and Phil on the same panel.
So,
what I'm going to talk about today, as you can see, is CAR T-cell therapy as
definitive consolidation therapy for older people with ALL.
I'm going to tell you a story in some ways about how we got
there. And at Michel's suggestion, I want to talk a bit about
the alternative target that we've been working on, the
BAF receptor and its potential in lymphoma and
then leukemia.
So the current challenges with people who have this disease
are toxicity and tolerability. The progress that's been made in
the treatment of this disease has really been inspired and led by pediatric
oncologists. In the adult side, we've moved it as
far into the adult as we could, but it is a challenge to get this sort of therapy
into people over the age of 40, 50, 60,
70. So you have abbreviated therapies.
You have people dying in remission.
There are certain high-risk genotypes that are more of a challenge for
chemotherapy, and these genotypes are more frequent in older people,
making the efficacy of such therapies less.
What influenced me a little bit about what I'm going to talk about is when we were
doing reduced intensity allogeneic transplants for people over the age of
60 and 70, I noticed when we looked at the
data that we could get really everybody through the transplant, but the
relapse rate was unacceptably high at 30, 40%.
And to take somebody through a curative therapy, put them through all that for a
relapse rate that high just struck me as not good enough.
In addition, there were sites of treatment failure with bispecific
blinatumomab in the central nervous system.
There's the data that you're all familiar with, where when people who do relapse
after CD19-guided therapy,
there's either antigen loss to explain it or just a modification of the epitope
itself, so it's not recognized, and there are limited cell
salvage options. So given all of that,
we continued our work with ALL like went on in New
York and at Penn and in Seattle,
to develop a CD19 CAR for treatment of patients with relapsed
ALL. And this is our contribution.
This is a series of 48 patients who we treated with a
CAR that we had made and a cell population we'd enriched for that had a
more of a naive phenotype. And what it shows you is
that
90% of the people went into remission,
and because these, unlike some children,
these remissions in the adults are really not long-lasting.
And you can see in the middle here... Let's see if I've got... Yeah.
These are the patients who went into remission but didn't get transplanted,
and these are the ones that did. So we began to see this therapy in the relapse
setting as a bridge to more definitive therapy with transplant.
One thing I wanted to point out to you, at least with the structure we were using,
we saw the typical expansion and contraction of cells with
some persistence out a-ways. But the thing that really caught our attention
also was that we could detect our CAR T cells in the CSF of every
single patient that was treated. And I'm going to come back to that idea in a
moment about what it may give us an opportunity to do.
So the questions we posed were, well, instead of chemotherapy, instead
of transplant, could we use CAR T-cell therapies in older
patients in their first remission
within three months of diagnosis?As a way of
avoiding three years of chemotherapy, as a way of avoiding a transplant.
But there were some things we just simply didn't know.
If these people in remission, would these CAR T-cells, that we put them in,
expand, which they need to do in order to really search and
destroy any last leukemia cell? Would they traffic to the
CNS and offer some protection? And most importantly, of course, is what
would be the durability of such a remission if you achieve it?
And the idea was, could you make a diagnosis, get a person into remission,
and rather than doing anything else,
do CAR T-cell therapy and then stop?
Patients were very interested in this approach.
We thought, given that we're talking about older people, that this would be
safer because the toxicity has been seen really in the other
programs. Disease burden and
disease burden for both neurological toxicity and just general
cytokine release were lower in patients who
were not so burdened with disease.
But of course, it begged the question, well, if it's safer, is it less
effective because you're not expanding in the usual things that we were worried
about?
So this was the design of the trial.
We were looking at patients who could get through this, of course.
We did do work on T-cell fitness, which in the question and answer period I'll try
to answer. So we picked patients over the age of 55.
They had been gotten into remission with standard chemotherapy.
They were in remission, and then rather than going through anything else, we
collected their T-cells, used our methodology, transduced them, expanded them,
and then infused them, as you can see along the bottom row.
This is the group of patients we've treated so far.
Their
age was 64, so they are older. And the disease
molecular characterization was
as noted below, and they all, because of the way people are treated right now, it
had pretty much blinatumomab and exposure.
So here's what we saw. We didn't see any dose-limiting toxicity.
We didn't see any grade two CRS cytopenias with what
we were expecting, and there were no deaths on study.
Now, we used the same product for these patients in first remission as we did for
the relapse patients. And what we saw was a huge difference in the
degree of toxicity generally and in particular,
neurological toxicity, which was at 80%, and in this setting was down
to 17%. So what we were hoping to be the case, at least in that
setting,
was realized. So we were relieved, to say the
least, about that. Did the cells expand in this setting?
The expansion looked pretty much the same as we'd seen in the relapse patient over
here. Again, this is in the first
month. Persistence was out here to about
four to five months with this one outlier,
and it correlates to the fact that we saw B-cell recovery.
When the CAR T-cells go down to a certain level, you see B-cell recovery, and
that's what we were seeing here. So it's not long-term surveillance that we're
inducing here, at least by this approach.
There's other things we're doing that are designed to extend that.
At least in this series, this is what it looks like in the first three months
after treatment. They do traffic to the
CNS because we did LPs in these people after therapy, whether they
did or not have disease. We didn't inject chemotherapy, but we tested to see
whether you could find these cells in the CSF, and a percentage of the
T-cells that were there were CAR.
So it is trafficking there, and I'll come back to that point in just a minute.
Because we were trying to preserve people's conditions so they weren't, if you
will, brutalized or handicapped by the therapies that we were doing,
we did cognitive performance, walking speeds, frailty scores, all those sort of
adjunct things that we do in oncology right now to try to assess what happens
to a person when you do something to them that's anti-cancer.
And what we saw was that their performance actually improved because we were seeing
them really after induction therapy, and so they regained pretty much back
to baseline after this. So we didn't think we were doing anybody
any harm. And the question is, did we do anybody
any good? And this is what it looks like so far.
So this is the first 18 patients. This is the overall survival. Everybody's alive.
And there were two patients who had a molecular relapse.
One was PH positive, one was not. They were retreated,
and they were taken to transplant.
So these two tick marks are on this curve.
So they're still
alive
and in remission.
So for this phase of the talk, we could see that we could actually
administer to older patients. It was safe.
They did well. They expanded even in a low antigen setting because we
weren't really sure whether that would happen.
The T-cells do get to the CSF, and we've not seen a CNS relapse so far.
And so we're doing a confirmatory
study supported by Autolus, who have really been our good
partners for a while
in exploring these. And it's going to be a multicenter trial at Memorial, City of
Hope, and Stanford for a larger number of people, 40,
30 of whom will have PH negative disease and 10 of whom will have PH positive
disease, and see if these early observations can be seen in a large
number of patients at different institutions.
And more importantly, can you really do something and finish
the therapy in the first three months from diagnosis?
That would be just wonderful if we could pull that off.
So we will see, and it'll be a field effort to make that happen.
But the other part of this talk that I'll finish with has to do with addressing CD
negative ALL relapse because everybody's getting blinatumomab as part of
the frontline therapy. When they relapse, I think it's
about 30% of the patients will have CD19
negative. And when you relapse post
blinatumomab, you can see that the survival,
either after blin or after CAR T-cells, is notGreat in
people who are adults. And with CD19, what we've
seen is that about 25%, 30% of the patients have relapsed, have
lost CD19, either from a selective pressure on a pre-existing
clone, which I think is probably the more common one than a
genetic mutation or alternative splicing.
They are mechanisms that work, but the point is that the
ScFv on the CAR won't recognize this, and therefore won't
target that leukemia cell. So the question is, what else could we do?
We've been working on another target, BAFF-R, on the context of
lymphoma. BAFF-R is a B-cell activating factor.
It's a member of the TNF superfamily, and it's pretty much expressed
on most B cells, from the early B cell all the way
to CLL. We were interested in it
because we thought, based on some B-cell biology, that it was
less likely to be deleted as a resistance mechanism since it
appeared to be an essential component of B-cell survival, which is the
reason why we were focused on it. So Larry Kwok
had generated a monoclonal antibody against the natively folded BAFF-R.
Our lab with Shuli Wang worked with his in developing a
second-generation BAFF-R CAR that was humanized, had a CD4
transmembrane domain, and a 4-1BB intracellular
signaling domain.
You've seen this slide a million times.
We all show the same sort of approach to apheresis,
transduction, and at a dose escalation of cells because this had not been
done before. It was another first-in-human trial
with standard lymphodepletion and then a CAR T cell infusion.
And the question is, what happened?
The cells expand.
This shows you just by copy number, and I think, yeah, this is by copy number, and
this is detecting
cells by flow. And they are very typical, at least in our hands, to what we
saw with CD19. It's about three to four months of detectability
by the methods we use, which is really molecular and by flow.
So you can't tell what target this is by this.
It looks kind of
the same.
There were no dose-limiting toxicities.
You can see in the bottom that toxicity was really well tolerated.
Some grade 1 and very little CNS toxicity.
And these are patients with active lymphoma.
And these are the results so far, the green being people who are
continuing in remission. And the trial hopefully will
continue to accrue over the next
year to really see what it can do in the various forms of lymphoma, which is
mantle cell and transformed lymphoma and large cell lymphoma of
B-cell type.
But this
section's about ALL. So the question is, what about ALL?
So I went to Larry, and I talked to him.
I said, "We ought to look and see whether this is expressed on pre-B ALL,"
because if you looked in the literature, it wasn't obvious that it was.
So we looked at 92 samples from 71 patients and found that it
was expressed in about 80% of the
patients. It is lower
than in mature B-cell neoplasms, so that was a concern.
And we saw that at least in the patients who had lost their CD19 because of
CD19 CAR or BLIN, they still expressed
BAFF-R in about two-thirds of the patients.
So it supported at least exploring whether the CAR we use for
lymphoma could be used to treat patients with
ALL in that setting. So we said, "Well, let's
do another first-in-human trial for patients with relapsed
ALL who had failed a CD19 CAR." That was the
patient population. We actually did preclinical studies.
Shuli Wang did this in her lab, which is right next to mine,
so I was seeing this evolve. And you can see in the
bottom that the BAFF-R CAR would
kill not only CD19-expressing leukemia
cells, but it would
target cells that had lost CD19. And
so we knew that we had a potential salvage for people who had lost CD19
due to prior therapy with a CD19-specific antibody, this
bispecific or a CAR T cells. So,
as you can see there, the BAFF-R CAR, unlike the CD19 CAR,
demonstrated anti-tumor activity against CD19-negative patient-derived
xenografts. And so that told us
it looks the same, it behaved the same.
What will it do in somebody who has
this disease? So we did this trial, which was led by Ibrahim
Aldos.
The City of Hope was at our other ALL trials. Same thing.
They failed or were ineligible for a CD19-targeted therapy,
and we accepted anybody who had BAFF-R expression.
And this concerned us because the antigen density or the
receptor density, I should say, on this cell is not what
CD19 is on a B cell. So we weren't exactly sure, the mice
notwithstanding, whether it would be seen by the
CAR.
And so that was one of the obvious questions that we had.
So these were the patients, and you can see dose level one, dose
level two. We were very much guided or restricted by the FDA, what
we could do, as fast as we could do it.
This was cyclophosphamide alone, followed by
the dose level one, and then we added traditional fludarabine
cyclophosphamide at the same dose.
This is a pretty low dose of CAR T
cells. And what we saw was that there was expansion,
just like they saw in lymphoma, in the patients with relapsed ALL.
This is copy number and percent by flow.
And this is what we've seen so far in the patients
who, in this most recent dose level, who got
the BAFF-R CAR with flu psi
and 50 million cells, they've all gone into
aA remission
in molecular with no detectable disease by
ClonoSEQ. So we believe there's a signal there
that there may be an alternative to people who have a CD19 relapse or who do
not express CD19. We've all been looking for this.
CD22 has been there. It's not
evolved the way I think people had hoped, and so I
treat all of this with considerable caution, even in our own group.
But we want to pursue this and see just where it will take us.
So it demonstrated favorable safety profile and
flirtatious, I would say, clinical activity in patients who had
progressed after a CD19-directed therapy.
There was expansion, and now we're going to complete an expansion phase and then
hopefully work on to a
larger number of patients. We have made, as Michel was
implying in his introductory remarks, a
bispecific CAR that expresses both
Baff-CAR,
scFv, and a CD19, because what we really want to do is
test that for patients with relapsed ALL to see if we
can get more people into remission deeper and
more durable.
So,
thank you for your attention. I'm grateful to Autolus for
partnering with us and going further, to the Leukemia Society,
who was the first person who looked at this and said, "We want to fund that,"
before the NCI did,
and of course, to the staff with whom I work with and the
field that's making this happen. So thank you very much.
So I'm happy to take questions. If you do, if you please go to the microphone
because there are people listening at home, who would like to be able to hear it
also.
Okay.
Steve, maybe I'll start with one.
It's about quantifying the level of
expression of either-
Of the Baff-CAR?
... CD19 or Baff.
Do you think that all these CD19 negative relapses are truly
CD19 absolutely negative, or
perhaps just CD19 very low? I don't know if you
find that important to make the distinction, but I wonder how you handle that.
So it's a good question, and we can get a little absolutist about what we know or
what we don't know. I think what you're observing is correct because in our
other models, which are mostly in the solid tumor space,
we have seen the level of an expression of a target go down low enough to where the
CAR doesn't see it even though we can detect it.
So there are issues related to antigen density expression.
I just don't know in CD19 whether those are absolute.
Clearly with the people who
had an epitope or a frame shift in
what constitutes the antigen, it's there, just as the CAR is blind to
it. But it's a good point. And you ask that question with what
in mind?
That we should
what?
Oh, I'm just curious if some of those CD19, quote, "negative," in fact,
could still be susceptible to a-
A CAR that had a more-
Yes.
Yeah. Okay, I see.
Yes, please.
Yeah, nice talk. I'm just wondering about
BaffR
expression dynamic range in ALL.
Did you say dynamic range?
Yeah, dynamic range. Because you say like-
Oh
... 78% of patient express, right?
Mm-hmm.
So how about the dynamic range? Like how many percentage of
cells express that target?
So what I was told by Abraham, who did this with the pathologist, he said he
was worried that the expression was low, certainly not
as what we see in other targets. And so there's even a variation
within the low. But we were taking, if we can detect it,
if we can see it at all, we allow people onto the study.
So another question, if the cell expression
has some kind of correlation with target expression?
With what?
With target expression.
I don't think so.
It's not a lot of patients yet, of course,
but I don't think we could see that those with the highest level of low
expression expanded better than the lowest level of low
expression. I think for the moment it's unknown.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you.
We'll take all three questions. I hope they're short questions or two questions.
My questions are kind of off the wall, but I'm just going to run them by you
anyway. Do you ever see epitope spread of any sort with CAR
T-cell therapy?
Mm.
And the other one is, do any of these B-cell directed
therapies have a potential role in other
non-malignant B-cell driven diseases like some of the really vicious
autoimmune diseases for which rituximab and such
antibodies are used?
So the second question is easy to answer.
The rheumatologists are really all agog about
utilizing these cellular-based therapies, in part because of
work that shows that you get a different type of depletion
with a cell than you do with antibodies. So we have done that.
We are seeing that, and trials are opening for that.
It's a big deal in the field, and the patients are knocking at the
door. With regard to the first question on antigen spread, I think what
we have seen, it's hard to see it in heme malignancy, but in solid tumors
for sure,
we have seen responses, certainly in our models,
and in some patients where we got a complete response.
But we knew that the tumor didn't express antigen across the board.
And so we think that's the engagement of an endogenous response, whether it's
epitope spreading or just liberating an endogenous anti-tumor response is what
I think is going on, and we want to focus on that because we think there are T-cell
receptors in that population that should be harnessed and
utilized as a partner to a CAR T-cell in a solid tumor.
That's the direction we're going in.
You showed this remarkable difference of cytokine release syndrome and
ICANS in patients that got the CARs in remission-
Yeah
... versus at relapse.
Yes.
So
you showed also 100% response rate and overall survival.
I think is this a matter of tumor load or what do you
explain this for?
So I think so. I think when
we see people who are getting these cells with advanced disease, whether it's
myeloma or lymphoma, leukemia, it's
a real adventure in that first month. So we were worried about that.
We were worried about two things, too much toxicity or not enough activity.
And I think what we have so far is it's not that toxic and there's a hint
of activity, and
for us right now, it's about durability.
Are we going to see relapses at two years, and what will they look like?
So time will tell us.
Thank you.
One last question from
the
online. Is your trial still open? Just a quick answer.
The BAF-AR clinical trial.
So we are
working to keep it open. It has to do with some relationship with the company and
everything,
for whom we made the virus. But we're going to make our own version of that and
keep going the BAF-AR, because there's a big need for that, for sure.
Okay. Thank you very much.
It gives me great pleasure to introduce our next speaker, Dr.
Phil Greenberg, who's professor
of medicine and professor of immunology at the Fred Hutchinson
Cancer Research Center in Seattle. He needs no introduction.
Phil, thank you for being here.
And I didn't get one, so that works.
Okay, so I'm going to try to go quickly through a lot of
material here about how we're trying to manipulate and
engineer an immune system so that it can work against tumors
in a solid tumor environment. So these are my disclosures.
None of them are really going to be terribly relevant to what I'm going to talk
about. So what's needed for a successful immunotherapy
targeting a solid tumor? Well,
you have to have a good tumor target antigen.
That's largely become a computation problem with the ability
to essentially sequence everything and find out
exactly what's uniquely or differentially expressed.
You need a receptor on the T cell that's efficient.
And again, that's now become a technical and/or synthetic engineering problem.
I'll show you some of the synthetic engineering that we're doing.
You need T cells able to infiltrate and recognize the tumor cells.
Again, that's partly cell processing, making cells that actually
can survive and home better.
But also, again, you can do some of this with synthetic
engineering. And finally, they have to persist in sustained
function. Once again, how you process the cells and
what kind of synthetic molecules you put in can have an
enormous impact on that.
So our studies in solid tumors really started when Ingunn Stromnes was a
postdoc in my lab. She now has her own lab in Minnesota.
And these studies have gone on now for quite a few years, quite a
few postdoc lives. Most of them have survived, actually.
And it was a collaboration with Sunil Angerani originally.
So this was the original paper we showed in this
engineered mouse KPC model. They spontaneously develop
pancreatic cancer that replicates the human disease.
And what Ingunn showed is that we could engineer T cells
expressing a mesothelium-specific TCR, now, not a CAR, TCR,
that they'd infiltrate, they would not only kill tumor cells,
but they cause stromal involution, so this dense fibroblastic reaction
disappeared. Unfortunately, though, they became dysfunctional.
And in order to get therapeutic advantage in those mice, we needed to do
repeated infusions. So we needed to do something to increase survival, and
I'll get to how we do that now. But we also showed that we
could generate human T cells also with a high affinity mesothelium
receptor, and that that would kill at least human pancreatic
cells in vitro. And so based on that, we initiated a clinical
trial,
with the expectation that we would be able to readily reproduce what we had seen in
the KPC model. And this was with Gabby and Ode directing it, and
Yapeng Xu, a postdoc in my lab, doing the analysis.
And what we saw was we gave T cells, and we would wait
21 days to analyze the toxicity.
If they were doing well, they would qualify for a second infusion and potentially
for a third infusion, always at least 21 to 28 days
later. We got tumor biopsies pre-therapy,
post-therapy, as well as a large number of blood samples to
analyze. So we treated nine patients on this trial.
Six of them got categorized ultimately as stable disease.
We clearly saw evidence of tumor shrinkage, but
none that would actually meet the resist criteria for being a formal
partial response. And all of these patients
eventually progressed. So to say the least, this was disappointing
and not what we were hoping for, although we saw that there was some evidence of
activity. But we thought maybe by analyzing
the outcome of this in more detail, we would get some insights in how
to make this better in patients. So this is looking at T
cells in the blood that have the TCR we put in.
We can barcode them. You can see we get a huge diversity of T
cells. This is over the whole course of time that we were
sampling.
But if you look at day seven, day 14, day 21, what we
see is mostly
stem-like memory T cells in the blood.
They start transitioning at day 21, but
these were functional T cells.Which
surprised us in terms of that we weren't seeing then a better response.
So we then looked at what we were getting out of the tumor biopsies.
This is, again, looking at
all the cells in the tumor biopsy. You can see the tumor and the T cell
clusters there.
But if
we then focus in on particular cells so that we only look at cells that
express the TCR, they're obviously seen in the T cell group, and the
mesothelin is expressed quite abundantly in the tumor group.
But if we now compare the molecular signature of these T cells in the tumor
to the molecular signature we were getting from single-cell RNA sequencing
in the blood, you can see that they hardly overlap. They're really quite distinct.
So what we're seeing in the tumor is very different than what we're seeing in the
blood. And predictably, what it was, was a lot of functional
signals. They weren't proliferating.
They expressed DIGIT, CD39, TIM3, PD1, all of the
inhibitory molecules. So we then looked at this in a little bit more
detail. This is now just looking at CD8 T cells in a tumor,
and I'm circling this cluster, which was a highly dysfunctional
population when we studied each cluster for function.
Perhaps not so surprisingly, those are all the T cells that expressed the TCR
that we had expressed in the T cells we gave.
They were quite distinct from the endogenous cells, which were the rest of the
cells, but most of these were bystander cells that were just pulled in by
the inflammation. So if you ask, do they function?
Well, those bystander cells are producing interferon if you stimulate them.
But these cells that we gave were no longer producing
interferon at day 21. They expressed TIM3 and all the other
markers. They expressed an exhaustion pathway.
But one of the things that was really distinctive was their exhaustion pathway
was not as severe as you see in classical canonical
exhaustion. They had exhaustion genes, but not to the same
extent. But what they did have is a very dominant TGF-beta
pathway signature, suggesting that they were seeing TGF-beta.
So we went back and looked now. We had done several different TCR trials,
and other people have looked at T
cells out of patients that were treated with infusions.
And we looked in melanoma, pancreatic cancer, breast
cancer, lung cancer, healthy blood, endogenous cells.
And I think what I just want to highlight here is how distinctive this was, that
the cells that we gave have an exhaustion signature, but
it's really different from what's, for example, reported in melanoma or in
mouse models in LCMV. It's a really mitigated signal
compared to the score you get in cells that become classically exhausted.
What they do have, though, is a very dominant TGF-beta signature.
And once again, that's not typically seen, for example, in TILs that come out
of melanoma, where there's a very minimal, if any, TGF-beta
signature. So that was a really unique aspect of this
issue, this disease. And the other thing is, which I think is probably
not surprising, is blood is not representative of what's happening in a tumor.
So the simple idea,
straightforward idea, that you would just get cells out of the blood and you could
monitor what was happening,
seemed pretty unclear, at least in this solid tumor.
So in order to actually start fixing this, we needed an analyzable model
to resolve those obstacles. And fortunately, that's what the KPC
mouse model of genetically engineered pancreatic cancer is so good for.
And without... I'm not going to show you the data.
This is a paper that's being submitted to Cell in the next week,
actually. But what we know is that the
KPC mouse replicated everything we saw in terms of this
molecular signature we saw in humans.
It was distinctive in terms of mitigated exhaustion and a
TGF-beta signal. So I'm not going to show you the blood analysis
and the single-cell analysis. I'm going to show you just the...
This is now looking at spatial transcriptomics.
This is an H&E stain or tumor biopsy from a patient from a mouse
treated. You get the same cell clusters if you do
spatial analysis using the
Visium and Xenium platforms. Mesothelin is
expressed in the area where the tumor is.
T cells are kind of found throughout the pancreatic
biopsy. But what's seen is there's kind of clusters of
cells. Some are in the tumor cell core, and there's others that
are in this cluster, which is largely
a tertiary lymphoid structure.
A whole variety of T cells. I'm going to focus on three classic types, the
TPECs, the T effector cells, and then this unique T
effector exhausted TGF-beta cell that we found in
humans also. And what you can see is the effectors and
the TPECs are all found in these lymphoid
aggregates that are near APCs, not in the
tumor core. And if you look where the cells that have this
exhausted TGF-beta signature, they're all embedded in
the tumor cluster itself. They've infiltrated.
They're in the cluster, but as you know, you already saw, they're not functional
anymore. And again, you can do this nearest neighbor analysis, and you can
see that the cells that have this exhausted signature are
all surrounded by tumor cells, and the cells that
have the functional phenotype are near endothelial cells, which is
classically where these TLS niches
form. So
there's a very unique signature here of highly dysfunctional cells.
It's associated with both persistent exposure to antigen, that's why they're
in the tumor core, and exposure to TGF-beta.
Now, the simple solution we thought was we could always knock out the TGF-beta
receptor, and particularly since it has a mitigated exhausted signature,
that ought to work well. Well, it didn't work at all, really.
What it did do is it got rid of the TGF-beta signature, but very
rapidly, these cells all acquire a
full-fledged exhaustion signature, now looking like the
classical T cell exhaustion signature you see in LCMV
or in melanoma.So that's not a solution.
So again, I'm skipping a lot of data.
This will obviously all be in the paper.
What we then did was a CRISPR screen, after doing a computational
analysis, trying to see, is there some master
transcription factor which we can potentially manipulate, which would
overcome both the exhaustion signature and the TGF-beta signature
concurrently? And indeed, what we saw was that
this was 180-gene screen, again, based on the computational
analysis. There was a single transcription factor which really stood out.
It's a gene called Aeolus. It's IKZF3, it's
also called. It's one of the targets of lenalidomide,
which knocks out Ikaros and
Aeolus.
It hasn't really been studied very much in T cells.
But if now we went back and looked at the mRNA in
melanoma, you could see that Aeolus is upregulated quite
dramatically in that setting. And when we did the
TGF-beta knockout and we looked, what we saw is that in the knockout,
Aeolus doesn't get upregulated, and that's consistent with the fact
that it is a TGF-beta responsive
gene. So TGF-beta, in part, drives Aeolus.
It's not the only thing that drives Aeolus.
So in the knockout, there's some expression, but it's essentially driven
both by exhaustion and by TGF-beta.
So based on that, we knocked out Aeolus and asked whether that would have an
effect. And we did a mixing experiment here, where we mixed
cells that were Aeolus knockout or not.
And what you can see is that they lose the TGF-beta signature,
and they have a very mitigated, if any, exhaustion signal
compared to control T cells. They function much better,
so that was all quite encouraging.
But the disappointing thing was that there was a
price to pay here, and that knocking out Aeolus resulted in less
surviving cells. And so we were a bit surprised and
disappointed by that. But then as we looked more into what
cells have a motif that binds Aeolus, it turns out that many of
the anti-apoptotic pathways are
also affected by Aeolus. And if you knock it
out, essentially, the cells undergo apoptosis, so they become good effector
cells, but they don't stay alive. And so this is kind of what
it looks like. You see the Aeolus improves therapy, but it's
not great. So we've worked on, and I'll talk about this a little later,
some fusion proteins that actually can provide survival
signals, overcome this activation-induced cell death, which
is induced through Fas, FasL, and Bb.
And you can see in that setting, we can essentially overcome this.
So this is telling us a bunch of things, and one of them, this was an old
paper that we had published in "Cancer Cell" looking at what's the
obstacles in the tumor microenvironment.
And I think what
you can see from the complexity is that a single modification is
not likely to resolve the problem in solid tumors.
And so it's going to require more, such as Aeolus and then a
survival signal, but it's going to require more than just
probably a single step to create cells that work.
So we then said, well, can we change some of these immunosuppressive signals that
these cells are receiving through inhibitory ligands and cytokines
and change that so that the cells actually benefit from them rather
than interfere? And this is kind of an interesting
strategy. You can essentially become the mad scientist, the kind of things
we all wanted to do when we started going in the lab.
But I think the problem has become, in the current context,
mad scientist is kind of taking on a different
stature. It's because these days, if you're not a mad scientist, you're just not
paying attention to what's actually going on right now.
So with that said, I'll get back to the study.
We've made these synthetic fusion proteins,
which essentially, as you can see, normally have inhibitory domains.
And what we do is we change their tails, so instead of providing inhibitory
signals, they provide costimulatory signals.
Or if we take something like Fas, we can change its death domain, which
is responsible for activation-induced cell death.
And if we put FasL on it, for example, we now get a
pro-survival and proliferative signal.
And essentially, you can rewire cells this way.
You
just use your imagination. For the number of inhibitory signals you can change
into, rather than being bad for the T cell, the fact that the ligand's there
becomes good. We also have done this with TGF-beta.
Ashley Tellon in the lab did this. We took the TGF-beta receptor, which
is a four-chain receptor. It's a little bit more complex than the IL-2 receptor.
But we swapped the cytoplasmic tails.
We went through a variety of constructs to make this happen, but essentially, we
can change a cell, a receptor that binds
TGF-beta into one that instead of suppressing the cell, delivers an IL-2
signal, and we published that the end of last year in
PNAS. It delivers an IL-2 signal. It attenuates the
TGF-beta signal,
but it doesn't fully eliminate it, which actually turns out to be important for
maintaining a cell stemness and survival.
So this is just showing you in an IncuCyte assay.
This is cells in a plate where we look at how the cells,
if they can kill them, as you can see,
if we put the TGF-beta/IL-2 receptor, they work.
They can kill tumors for over 150 hours, where the TCR alone
doesn't work. And they not only kill it, but they actually proliferate.
Again, they're getting their own IL-2 signal.
So this functions both as a dominant negative to the native TGF-beta
receptor, and it also takes advantage of the fact that they're going to see
TGF-beta, so turn it into something good rather than just ignore it.
So there's other things to do. So one is we
actually reported back in the 1980s the critical role of CD4 cells in
antitumor responses. It's quite clear from all the checkpoint blockade and the CAR
cells, CAR T cell story, that CD4s are very important.
But so far, what we were talking about was engineering CD8 cells.
We know CD4 cells provide help. They provide indirect killing.
They activate B cells.A little less appreciated is this
critical role of CD4 cells with exhausted cells.
And we're calling this CD4 assistance because the mechanism isn't really
quite well known. But
CD8 T cell exhaustion is in part a
reflection of the lack of getting adequate CD4 help.
And that's why in, for example, in the LCMV model, CD4 cells are
depleted before you actually infect them with Clone 13.
So we said, could we build a CD4 cell to work in this system
without having to mix and match class
II molecules with class I molecules and have two separate sets of
TCRs? So we know we can put a TCR into CD8 cells, and it'll
kill, get activated well. We say, can we put that same high
affinity TCR into CD4 cells, and you
get a signal with that. It isn't very good.
But if you put in CD8 alpha beta as well as the TCR, you give the
CD4 cell the same avidity as the CD8 cell, and that does
work, but it works even better if we put in one of these fusion proteins that
provides co-stimulation. CD4 cells really appreciate
getting a costimulatory signal, and then they work much better.
The slides here are showing you that. This is, again, HICASE assay.
If you put in tumor alone, it grows out quite quickly, and it
overgrows the culture. If we put in CD4 cells with just the TCR,
they don't do anything either. But if we add CD8 alpha beta to those
CD4 T cells, they work quite well, but again, they can't quite
eliminate the tumor. We're adding fresh tumor every 48 hours.
But if we put in CD8 cells, they work better, but again,
they start losing activity over time in the absence of CD4 help.
But if we mix fours and eights at a one-to-one ratio, so they're the same
total number, they actually clear the tumor each time we keep adding it.
So they maintain function, and they continue to have anti-tumor
activity. And this got published recently.
We're also developing now a mouse model to study this.
I can't go through what the obstacles were doing that, but Jeanette's working on
that. And we're also developing a multicellular human
organoid system to actually study it in human cells in vitro.
But I just want to show the importance of adding co-stimulation to that
system. So this is the TCR with
CD8 alpha beta and the TCR. This is adding the 28 signal to
it. This is an
irrelevant TCR, and we put this into NSG mice
that we transplanted human melanoma into.
And I think what you can see is the final tumor volume, and I'm not showing you
all the data obviously, but the cells with the CD28 costim now
work much, much better than they do without it.
And this is just to show you graphically. I hope this is projecting well.
The irrelevant TCR doesn't get into the melanoma.
The TCR with CD8 alpha
beta, the fours and eights do get in.
But if we add co-stimulation, you can see there's far more cells in.
And the reason that that
piece of tissue is smaller, it's because it's actually being rejected.
So this was nine days after infusion, and you can see already the tumor is getting
much, much smaller than its counterparts.
And if you blow up that area, you can see there's loads of four and eights that are
now in the tumor, and those cells have clearly expanded.
So based on this, we've started a trial in using a
KRAS TCR
in humans with, again, putting in CD8
alpha beta and a TCR. This is A11 restricted.
We've treated four patients now. They get treated at
four dose levels. We're just about getting ready to start the second
group. We also, Affinity, a company that we
had founded,
did a concurrent trial using the TCR, CD8 alpha beta,
and the FES Forum BB IFP. I can't quite report that one yet, but
I will tell you that data looks yet better.
So these are the four patients we treated.
I have that patient nine in gray because the patient was just
treated, and so I have just one data point on that patient.
This is the three patients. I don't have any longitudinal data
on patient nine.
But all of these patients showed evidence of anti-tumor activity.
So this is looking at the change in the target lesion.
You can see one patient actually didn't shrink, just had stable disease.
Two patients had significant shrinkage.
If you look at their tumor markers, CEA
for colon, CEA 99 for pancreatic cancer, those
all went down dramatically. And this last patient we just treated also
dramatically decreased that biomarker.
If you look at ctDNA,
I have this on just two patients. Both of them, they completely cleared the
ctDNA, but you can see on this one patient, came back by day 100.
This other patient came back around day 60.
If you take tumor biopsies from these patients, this is the
patient showed a tumor reduction.
You can see in the pretreatment, there was lots of tumor.
In the post-treatment biopsy, there was very little
tumor around. There was more T cells.
If we looked at the CD4 cells that were in the tumor, now I'm just showing you
there the CD4 cells that have the TCR on the left.
And then you can see that if we stain for what genes are expressed, they're
expressing perforin, granzyme B, Tbet, and very
little exhaustion markers. So they're looking quite functional.
The same thing we can say for the CD8 cells.
They express TCF7. They don't express exhaustion
markers. And they express markers like
ZNF683. That's HoBIT. It's tissue-resident memory cells in
CD69. So even at these low doses, these cells are looking
good.This is looking at the second
patient. This is the patient who actually, by contrast,
the tumor actually progressed by day 56.
And now when we look at the tumor at the T cells, you can see the four cells
are actually all exhausted and that's true for the CD8
cells as well.
And so we obviously need to do more, and one of them is obviously to put in these
IFPs
or provide co-stimulation in some way to enhance their persistence.
So the last thing I just want to talk about is whether we can
expand this by
getting TCRs to more common HLA alleles like HLA-A2.
In this, we developed a strategy to isolate high affinity
TCRs very efficiently. I'm not going to go through the detail.
It's basically just a strategy for pulling out high affinity
receptors. We used AI to design
TCRs. So here's what happened. We generated TCRs to a peptide,
HLA-A2 peptide, a K RAS
G12V that binds HLA-A2. We generated TCRs that
looked very good by tetramer staining.
We then looked at pancreatic tumors, and despite the fact that I'm showing
you our two best TCRs, one killed it very well and one didn't, which
seemed confusing. So we said, "Well, this is strange.
Let's look at another tumor line." And it turned out we got exactly the
opposite result. The TCR that didn't work well now worked well, and the one
that did work well didn't work at all.
I'm not going to go through all that data.
These observed differences turned out to reflect the fact that this
epitope is getting post-translationally modified by methylation.
It's a common event. K RAS actually
upregulates kind of the methylome in pancreatic
tumor cells. And so we looked at what the impact of that was.
So the
one lysine that can get methylated is at the P1 position of the
epitope. I'm just showing you where it is.
If you show it on its side, you can see this really sticks up, so it's very
likely a TCR contact point, and if you methylate it, it
starts rotating down into the groove as opposed
to sticking up as well. And that would impact TCR recognition.
We then
used AlphaFold to look at, and Rosetta,
the two different programs that are, since Rosetta is much better at
looking at post-translational modifications, at what part of
the TCR was likely contacting it. We found four
positions in the TCR alpha sequence, and so
we then did saturation mutagenesis of that region.
And what we saw was we could get TCRs that unlike the
original TCR, just for those two
amino acids, the D and N, that
actually changed whether they saw the methylated, the
original, or both. And based on that,
we've isolated TCRs that look quite promising.
We now have TCRs that can kill both the
tumor that does make methylated peptide and the tumor that doesn't.
When we, again, look at-- This is just looking at the TCR on the whole thing.
I want to show you, this is not to ignore the critical mutational
epitope, but that's actually seen by the beta chain of the TCR, not the alpha
chain that we're modifying. And we've most
recently, in collaboration with Wilfried Pastor and Gerson
Gonayden at Dana-Farber, Sammy
Barkho, my lab has been working with them.
We've been looking at T cell killing of a human PDA tumor organoid.
And as you can see, these tumors, actually, these mutated
TCRs now that we designed, synthetically designed, actually,
are dramatically better. There's a whole bunch of other approaches
that we're doing. I'm not going to talk about any of them.
I just want to give credit to the people who have done the studies.
And I tried to highlight them actually during the talk. So thank you.
Thank you. Thank you, Phil, for sharing these wonderful stories.
First question there, I see.
Hi, Phil. Thank you so much for sharing such inspiring stories.
So,
my question is about CD4 T cells.
So we have seen that CD4 T cells can be highly cytotoxic
when they are tested in in vitro killing assay, but I was always wondering
how cytotoxic they stay when they get into the patients.
And you show that those CD4 TCR T cells express
granzyme and perforin at mRNA level, but are they really cytotoxic?
For example, if you test them in ex vivo killing assay, do they
kill tumors?
Yeah. So we've tested them in incoside assays. They are cytotoxic.
And they clearly become much more cytotoxic when they're in the
environment of chronic stimulation than they
are-- At least our processing pathway doesn't make
them highly cytotoxic when they go in, but they differentiate into cytotoxic.
They're very TH1-like when they go in.
They become TH1-like and cytotoxic after they're in.
Okay.
Hi. Sneha Ramakrishna, Stanford. Really beautiful talk.
I'm very impressed with your tumor biopsies, and I'm just curious, are the
T cells you're seeing more endogenous T cells, or can you
identify your TCR engineered T cells?
And is the transcriptional signature different between endogenous
and the engineered?
Yeah. So I'm sorry, I probably just went through that too quickly.
I tried to show those blue dots were all just cells that were
expressing the TCR we put in, and they're very different from the
endogenous cells. But we believe that most of the endogenous cells we're
seeing are just passenger cells. We have very little evidence that any
of them are actually ever getting activated or seeing anything in the tumor
microenvironment. But they're pulled in when we give our T cells,
they create inflammation, and so lots of cells traffic, and
we presume transiently are getting
caught and stuck in that environment.
So the signature is completely different for the cells we're
putting in, which are being chronically activated.
Thank you.
One last question.
Nice talk. Thank you. So I might miss something, but I'm wondering
why you choose KRAS G12V
instead of KRAS G12C, because I
feel like a G12C mutation is more dominant
in pancreas cancer, right?
No.
Actually, no. So G12C is actually quite rare in pancreas.
Okay.
G12V and D are the common mutations in pancreas.
Oh, okay. So, for that one, what's the
purpose? The purpose is to
make the TME more
favorable for
cell expansion, right?
To make the T-
Make the TME environment more favorable, right?
Yes.
Yeah.
Well, either that or take advantage of what's bad in the
TME and,
by rewiring, convert that into a positive signal for a T cell.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you, Phil, very much.
Well, for this last
talk today in this session, we go back to the receptors themselves.
Here are my disclosures, nothing to do with this presentation.
So these are the two CARs that I mentioned earlier that I think you all know of,
which are at the source of this emerging field,
which combine the signaling domains of CD3 zeta
and either CD28,
as we had published long ago in 2002,
or 4-1BB, as was first reported by Dario Campana
at St. Jude.
What I would like to discuss with you today are novel CAR designs, which I
think
would provide advantages over these
archetypes, and I'm going to discuss three of them.
One that we call 1XX, then one that we call HIT, and that one that
has the acronym of 1A.
The 1XX CAR brings me back to really the first
CARs
that combined successfully the zeta chain signaling
domain with that of CD28.
As we soon learned from the clinic,
these and the 4-1BB CARs were both effective
in
leukemias, in particular acute lymphoblastic leukemias,
and both were also effective in a series of
non-Hodgkin lymphomas, perhaps the CD28 CAR overall showing a greater
efficacy. But we also learned that the CD28-based CAR
was short-lived, and we and others probably assumed that that was an
intrinsic property of CD28. But after
so many years, we thought we should revisit this question, focusing on the
zeta chain component, which has these three green domains that you see here
in the upper right.
If this works. No, this mouse doesn't work.
That are the ITAMs that are well-defined in basic immunology.
So this is old work published already, so I'll just summarize by
saying that the CAR that comprised a single ITAM, not the
three natural ITAMs in the proximal
position called 1XX, really outperformed
others in very stringent
animal models that we call stress tests, where, as exemplified here,
the established Nalm6 ALL
is treated with very low doses of T cells.
And so we brought this to a clinical trial, and this is this molecule here in the
middle called 19-1XX. It was a new
human SCFV,
but I'm not going to dwell on that. I just want to focus on the
key finding of this trial. We had
hypothesized that this 1XX CAR, if it were really
more effective than the classic CAR,
that it should produce the same results but in much lower dose.
In the yellow box here, you see the bottom two are the doses
of the
FDA-approved CAR T cells, the 4-1BB CAR
TisaGen that typically requires infusion about 300 million
CAR T cells per patients in adults, and the one called
axicell or Axi-CAPTAgene, which
requires a CD28-based CAR that actually uses our
sequence
and requires about half the dose. Those are bulk cell populations, a
bit
different from the one-to-one ratio adjusted in the top product.
So anyway, we started this trial at the dose of
25 million CAR T cells
and dose escalated from there. And so this was published last year, so
I'll apologize for being very brief.
As you see in the lower left here, in the dose escalation phase, we had good
responses in patients with refractory diffuse large B-cell
lymphoma. Two-thirds or three-quarters of them, but noticeably
no dose response. And so we decided to do the expansion
cohort, not at the maximum tolerated dose as is conventionally done,
but at the lower dose of 25 million CAR T cells.
And as you see in the bar graph to the far right, with a total of
16 patients receiving 25 million CAR T cells, we
observe this excellent complete remission rate,
very low toxicity consistent with our second hypothesis that a
lower dose of CAR T cells would result in a lower severity and
frequency of toxicities, and durable responses.
That's what you see in the swimmer plot to the right, where these
responses were as durable as any of the
commercially available CARs. So you could achieve at least as well as
with those approved products, but using only 25 million CAR
T cells.And I'm very pleased that two other groups, Jonas Madsen
in Toronto and Cynthia Bamdad in
Boston,
were interested in this 1XX CAR and compared it to
4-1BB, again, the classic 4-1BB and CD28 CARs.
I don't know why there's a timer on this, but
compared it to the classic CD28 and 4-1BB CARs in
animal models above targeting mesothelin in an orthotopic model of
ovarian cancer. In the bottom, targeting a truncated version of
MAC-1 called MAC-1 star in a breast cancer model.
And both studies found that this
1XX CAR did again outperform those classic
versions.
We opened another trial
where we added another layer to this engineering,
and that goes back to even earlier work where we had shown with
Justin Ekwem and Joachim and Silas Soto that if you control the
level of expression in your T cells,
you might
achieve an optimal level of expression, not too low, not too
high,
which allows you to, again, infuse even fewer
CAR T cells, since each and every one of them
expresses the CAR at an optimal level.
So we brought this to the clinic. Again, my colleague Isabelle Rivere developed the
IND. Jay Park led the trial. We didn't have money to
complete the trial, but I'm pleased to report on the first three
subjects infused in this trial. And here we started
with 10 million CAR T cells.
For those not familiar with the field, 10 million CAR T cells is a dose that
you see infused
in mice sometimes. I should add, this is a seven-day protocol to
which this dose should be compared.
And so you see in those first three patients, two of them remain in durable,
complete remission after 27 or 31 months.
One of them did relapse with CD19 negative
disease, and again,
very low toxicities.
So what I conclude from 1XX CARs is that it is
worth balancing
the strength of activation and co-stimulation
to reconcile potency and persistence.
You can now treat patients with 25 million CAR T cells on a seven-day protocol,
not 100-plus million CAR T cells. And on a
three-day production protocol, this dose is
even lower.
With the TRAC engineered cells, 10 million CAR T cells
suffice. And I think this has good consequences.
Obviously, it will obviate the need for apheresis from
patients. It should decrease the cost of production.
And I think the 1XX CAR is also particularly well-suited for in vivo
use. And in fact, that's the
CAR that Nyberg et al. in Justin Ekwem's
laboratory recently used in their "Nature" paper
showing us how to CRISPR-engineered T cells at the TRAC
locus in vivo.
My second story focuses on the sensitivity of CARs.
And again, the clinic taught us,
as
Steve just told us about earlier in this session, that some patients will
relapse with, of course, antigen-negative tumor, but sometimes
tumor that still expresses the antigen but at a lower level than
pretreatment. And this drew our attention to our interest
to what is the sensitivity of these CARs.
So you all see here on the left, the physiological T cell receptor,
the far right, the type of CARs that I've been discussing.
And we wanted to compare a T cell receptor and a CAR, and to do
so, created this structure that you see in the middle, where the
heavy and light chains of an immunoglobulin of the CAR substitute for the
alpha and beta regions of the T cell receptor.
And we named this HIT, which simply stands for an
HLA-independent T cell receptor.
And again, we reported
a few years ago that these HIT receptors are indeed more sensitive
than the most sensitive of all CARs, which are the
CD28-based CARs.
I want to show you a new story, although it was very recently published,
that further demonstrates what you can achieve with this
type of CAR design. The target in this case is CD70,
and the disease now is renal cell carcinoma.
And we have these patient-derived xenografts
established from patients with advanced and refractory to
multiple treatments, RCCs. And so I
show you here in the left part of the graphic, the
treatment of mice harboring these PDX models.
The upper panel, the PDX is in the lung, and
the lower panel, where you see all those bioluminescence
curves, the same PDX is in the kidney.
And an infusion of one million of these conventional CAR T cells or
1XX CAR T cells was very effective in the lung but
failed in the kidney.
We further increased the dose to five and even 10 million CAR T cells in
mice harboring the kidney tumor but still could not eliminate those tumors.
We thought we had
perhaps a
challenge in entry of these T cells into the tumor at the kidney
site, but that was not the case. And we soon realized that these
PDX models, which I didn't show you, are CD70 positive, bright
in culture,
change expression of CD70 in vivo.
And on the far right there, you see by FACS analysis with one of those
PDX models called K5, the bright expression of CD70 in the
lung and the downregulation, and apparently even negative
fraction at the kidney. Same thing below with the K7 PDX model.
Bright expression in the lung, but diminished or absent in the
kidney. And the immunohistochemistry there shows you the PDX
model at the kidney site, which is actually very reminiscent of human
tumors.I won't digress here into
what accounts for this variability in CD70
expression, but Sophie
looked deep into that and found that at the kidney site,
a number of
these PDX cells
will
recruit EZH2 to the CD70 promoter.
And you can see here, if you look quickly on the left, in the CD70 negative
fraction, you see this
tri-methylation of lysine 27 on histone 3 that is
characteristic of silenced transcription appearing in that
fraction. And when you take these cells out of the mouse and put them back in
culture, over a week or so, they reacquire CD70
expression. So it's clearly epigenetically regulated
and under the influence, in this case, of the anatomical
location, lung versus kidney. But I'll get back
to my story, which is really about the sensitivity of these receptors.
So we realized that these
PDX cells that silence CD70 expression don't silence it
completely. There's still low-level expression you can detect with good
microscopes and not conventional microscopes, CD70 protein.
And so we thought we could treat these mice with a HIT receptor.
And going quickly to the BLI on the far right there, you can see these green
lines, the precipitous decline in tumor burden after an infusion of these
HIT CD70-targeted HIT T cells, which
again, in the upper lines there in blue and purple, cannot be achieved
with the conventional CAR. Now, some of these mice relapsed over time,
and so we added a costimatory
signal into these T cells, which is a combination of CD80 and
4-1BB ligand,
just a trick that we've used and that others have used too over many years.
And now you see in those red lines the complete
eradication of these tumors.
It was so good, actually, we feared that these cells may have off-target activity,
and so Sophie again created a
variant of the PDX models in which the CD70 gene was ablated.
And by mixing back into the PDX this truly negative fraction, you
can see in these purple lines in two models that now the HIT
CD70
CARs failed, showing that they really had to engage antigen on
the cell surface. And lastly, I'll just say that we think this goes
beyond renal cell carcinoma. Here are two other models, one of ovarian cancer at
the top and one in a pancreatic adenocarcinoma model.
You can see their CD70 expression on the left, ex vivo, retrieving
it from their orthotopic location.
It's variable, but some cells are positive and some are negative.
But in the far right, you see that again, this HIT receptor is successful
in every case. And so
these HIT receptors are truly far more sensitive than conventional
CARs. CD70, in particular, is epigenetically
regulated, and although this is not my topic for today,
we think that assessing chromatin accessibility is a better
predictor
for sensitivity
to a CD70 HIT receptor, because as I said, it's actually very
difficult to measure using conventional assay
expression of CD70 at the surface.
Lastly, I want to discuss
this CAR that we call a 1A CAR.
And with Yu-Chih Shih, we were reflecting on T cell development that you
see up on the diagram and thinking about
the pre T cell receptor, which forms after
successful rearrangement of the beta chain and pairing with an
invariant chain called a pre-TCR alpha chain.
And what caught our interest is that at this stage, these T
cell wannabes, if you like, undergo extensive
expansion,
1 to 200 fold, and evidently without undergoing any
exhaustion. And so we turned to the literature, but the
literature doesn't tell you much about how this pre-TCR signals, and so we
incorporated a portion of the
cytoplasmic domain in the 28 zeta CAR.
And here I'll show you a part of this work very quickly.
This is in different models comparing the 1A CAR to the classic
FDA-approved, if you like, CD28 zeta CARs.
In the upper part, in this stress test in the NALM6 model, you can see the
1A CAR vastly outperforming the classic 28 zeta CAR.
In the lower left, the orthotopic kidney response, and in the
right, two models of glioblastoma, either subcutaneous
or orthotopic. These also express CD70, and you can
see that the CD70
1A CAR vastly outperforms,
again, the classic CAR. So this work was just published
just a few weeks or days ago.
So I'm going to skip many details and just tell you that in these mice, we
found evidence of strong effector functions persisting
longer than in the 28 zeta CAR, the classic CAR, and
with minimal induction of exhaustion, and this was kind of a paradox
to resolve. And so what Yu-Chih Shih did is to
start from
phosphoproteomics studies after exposing these 1A CARs to
their antigen and quickly identified as one of the most
differentially phosphorylated proteins, YBX1,
which you see here in the lower left in the western blot,
that YBX1 is phosphorylated after engagement of 28 zeta
CARs, but more durably in the case of the
1A CAR. Turns out YBX1 is a master
regulator of mRNA translation.There's very
little literature on it in T cells, but much more in some cancer
cells. It sequesters mRNAs in the cytoplasm and
prevents them actually from being translated.
These mRNAs are released upon the
phosphorylation of YBX1, and knockout studies here, ablation
studies, confirm the critical role played by
YBX1. So I'll be very brief to go to the mechanism.
But
Yujie performed a ribosomal footprinting sequencing, a Ribo-seq.
And what I'm showing you here is what's called the translation efficiency,
which is a ratio, if you like, of ribosome-protected
fragments to the abundance of a given mRNA.
And what you see is that there are very many, all those red dots,
genes that show increased translation
efficiency. Well over 1,000 of these mRNAs show
increased
translation, and they fall largely in what's called the TPT-1 and
the E1F3
interactomes. Meaning what this is doing is boosting
translational activity, ribosomal biogenesis,
and efficiency of translation. And by ChIP-seq,
she did find that indeed YBX1
does bind to a number of these mRNAs, and perhaps the
one picture to excerpt from this study is in the lower right there.
You see in those blue dots, the mRNAs extracted from the
classic CAR T cells and the ribosomes are either stalled or paused
near the start codon. And you can see that those same mRNAs
extracted from the 1A CAR show ribosomes that are
moving down the
mRNA.
So 1A CARs drive strong and extended effector functions.
They act through YBX1
to increase RNA translation globally, and I think this
observation opens yet another angle for
controlling T cells in immunotherapy by
regulating mRNA translation. And to finish, I just want to go
back to my first slide. Those are the two CARs that were FDA
approved in 2017 on the left.
I don't think that they're obsolete.
They still are used in autoimmunity, and they still may be useful
in some cancers, but I think that today there's
such better designs really to be
exploring, especially in solid tumors.
The 1XX CARs are more durable. The HIT CARs are more sensitive.
The 1A CARs are more potent.
And I thank you for your attention.
Hi. Gil Omenn, University of Michigan.
Yes.
I was really struck by your early slide about the CAR
protocols where you couldn't use large numbers of cells, and you
performed very effective treatments in two or three patients, at least,
with
much smaller dosage, much lower cost, presumably.
Yes.
Much less delay.
Is anybody else doing something similar to this?
And where does this-
Yes
... thread continue?
Yes. No, there's considerable effort by many groups to
lower this dose requirement in CAR T cell
therapies. What many groups have done is to shorten gradually
the
duration of manufacturing. In the very beginning, it was typically 10,
12, 14 days, sometimes more. In recent years,
the standard became seven days, at least at our centers and other leading
centers.
And some have now moved to three days and even overnight.
In this instance, though,
the
manufacturing was kept the
same, and the
diminished dose owes to, if you like, the superior activity of
these CAR T cells. But anyway, so there are many different approaches that
all in all lead to reducing
these dose requirements.
Yeah.
Hi. I have a mechanistic question about your single ITAM
zeta chains.
Do you think it's just a LAT flux? Like how much LAT is getting there and-
No
... sending on to ZAP, or is it... Sorry, I said that backwards.
Or is it possible there's different proteins like phosphatases being actually
recruited to the TCR itself, and the signal from the TCR is different?
Unfortunately, I don't have the answers to that.
I wish, but I'll leave that to biophysicists and biochemists, but I
think there's something very
worthwhile to investigate there. I don't have a better answer for you.
I don't know if you're familiar with the altered peptide ligand literature that's
really-
Yeah.
Yeah. So they looked at that question a lot.
Yeah. But this is not a CD3. This is not a TCR in the CD3 complex either.
Even the phosphatases are not recruited, and actin, of course, and
many other things in the way these-
Yeah, but they're also missing LICK, right? So.
Exactly.
So there's-
There are so many differences.
Really inspiring talk. I'm curious, have you thought about combining
all three CARs, maybe not in the same cell, but in the same treatment paradigm?
Because you're getting three different modalities.
Yeah.
And so maybe you could better represent a true T cell immune response?
I'll give a
general answer to your question.
A lot of T cells today target two antigens, right?
And either using one CAR that can
engage two antigens or by putting two receptors in the same cell.
That seems to make a lot of sense, but it's not so simple.
You can easily overload or overwhelm a T cell with too many
receptors and accelerate its exhaustion, really.
You might not see that if you only do short-term assays.
You can make a T cell that kills two antigens.
But over time, I can assure you that their
decline might be accelerated. So we find that some of
theseCan be combined without
aggravating, if you like, the exhaustion, and that's what we're doing right now.
So I hope to give you a good answer in a year or so.
But to clarify, not in the same cell.
Yeah. In the same cell.
You have three different products and-
In the same cell.
No, but not in the same cell.
Like using three different CAR products at once.
Oh, I see what you... Well,
I think it's rarely done. Mostly because
this field being
very interested in the clinical application, the manufacturing of multiple
products is expensive,
and so I think few
have followed that path. Sometimes you have two CAR T cells combined
targeting two antigens.
There are a few studies that have followed that path.
But I don't claim to know them all well enough to
give a final readout on this, but they have not
proven to be any better than the infusion of one cell
seeing two antigens. But I would say that there's not enough data there to be
conclusive.
Yep. Thank you.
Thank you for the great talk. So I wonder how Hit
CAR would behave against the antigen density high
tumor target because the density of peptide-MHC
complex is that a given TCR can recognize much, much lower
compared to, for example, CD19 in B cell.
So if you use such a sensitive receptor for high
density antigens, is there any downside like fast exhaustion
or something?
Yeah. Good question. We haven't looked very hard because our focus is really on the
low antigen.
Yeah.
This doesn't function like a T cell receptor.
The chains have to have high affinity.
If you go to the micromolar range like a T cell receptor, they don't work anymore.
Mm-hmm.
I'll point out that they don't engage HLA peptides, so they don't get
assistance, to borrow Phil's term,
from CD4 or CD8. So they don't exactly signal like-
Oh, okay
... T cell receptors either, but they are more sensitive.
Thank you.
And last question then we have to stop.
Yeah. Considering the extremely high specificity of Hit CAR, how are you
addressing the possible issues of on-off tissue
effects-
Yeah
... on normal tissues?
Yeah. A very good question. You can't have it both ways, right?
If you're more sensitive, you will hopefully close the door to tumor
antigen escape,
but your concerns on on-target activity on normal cells
increase. So far we can't have it
both ways. So we're looking hard for what cells express CD70 in the
body. Of course, immune cells do. That is well known.
T cells and K cells and B cells upon activation.
But beyond that, all we've found so far is the esophagus.
Don't ask me why the esophagus has a very low fraction of
CD70 positive cells, and it's not an artifact.
We worked quite hard to make sure that it was real.
It's a very tiny percentage.
Beyond that I think that the answer will have to come from clinical trials.
Thanks.
I thank everyone for your attention.
I thank
our two marvelous speakers today, Phil
Greenberg and Steve Forman. This session is now
closed.